en el vídeo pasado pudimos establecer
está integral usando el método de
cascarones o de los cilindros delgados
para calcular el volumen desde sólido de
revolución evaluamos entonces este
integral y para esto lo único que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicar estas
dos cosas aquí tenemos que multiplicar
estas dos expresiones esto es igual a 2
pisa con la constante 2 pide la integral
la integral de 0 a 1 que multiplica 2
por raíz de x 2 y raíz de kilo a poner
de manera más conveniente como x a la un
medio esto es la manera más conveniente
para facilitar la integración así 2 raíz
de x es igual a 2 x al un medio 2 x - x
cuadrada es menos 2 x cuadrada luego
tenemos que menos x por raíz de x es x a
la 1 x x al medio esto nos va a dar a
menos x a la 3 medios luego menos x x -
x cuadrada esto va a ser igual a más x
cúbica y todo esto
y ya estamos listos para tomar la anti
derivada esto va a ser igual a 2 por la
anti derivada de todo esto evaluado en 1
y 0 veamos entonces aquí tenemos la anti
derivada de 2 x x al un medio esto va a
ser 2 x x a la 3 medios por dos tercios
esto va a ser igual a cuatro tercios x a
la tres medios cuatro tercios x a la
tres medios más la anti derivada de
menos dos x cuadrada la cual va a ser
menos dos tercios de x cúbica recuerda
que siempre puedes verificarlo derivando
y obteniendo esto luego tenemos la anti
derivada de menos x a la tres medios la
anti derivada de menos x a la tres
medios es igual a x a las cinco medios
por dos quintos sería menos dos quintos
dejar ponerlo en otro color que tenemos
entonces la anti derivada de menos x a
la tres medios va a ser igual a menos
dos quintos x a las cinco medios si
checa cinco medios y dos quintos
finalmente la anti derivada de x kubica
quizá la cuarta sobre cuatro vamos a
ponerlo también con otro color esto va a
ser más x a la cuarta sobre cuatro es la
anti derivada de este término bueno sólo
nos queda evaluar esta expresión en 0 y
1 pero para nuestra fortuna los términos
en 0 se cancela bueno se evalúan en 0 y
todos se hacen 0 así es que sólo hay que
evaluar en uno esto es igual a 2 pi que
multiplica a evaluamos en una esta
expresión va a ser igual a cuatro
tercios
menos dos tercios
menos dos quintos menos dos quintos y
más un cuarto
+ 14 y sacando el mínimo común múltiplo
de los denominadores este es igual a 60
por lo cual esto va a ser igual a 2 pi
que multiplica a como un denominador 64
tercios en términos de 60 es igual a 80
sobre 60 luego tenemos menos dos tercios
que es igual a menos 40 sobre 60 luego
menos dos quintos que esto es igual a
menos 24 sobre 60 y finalmente más un
cuarto que es igual a más 15 sobre 60 y
esto va a ser igual a simplificamos este
2 con 60 para obtener 30 en el
denominador tenemos en el numerador 80
menos 40 es igual a 40 40 menos 24 esto
nos va a dar
16 16 más 15 nos va a dar 31 entonces
tenemos 31 por pi sobre 30 31 por pi
sobre 30 es el volumen de nuestro sólido